the bravely series has always excelled
at evoking the feeling of playing
classic final fantasy style rpgs
while sanding off some of the rough
edges that may make those classic games
less approachable to modern audiences
bravely default 2 confusingly enough the
third game in the franchise
maintains much of its predecessor's
retro charm but it actually removes some
of the quality of life features that
made the first two such breezy nostalgic
throwbacks
instead of simply reminding you of the
satisfaction of playing a classic rpg
bravely default 2 demands that you
relive the entire experience
faults and all
[Music]
for the uninitiated bravely default gets
its namesake from its innovative risk
reward combat system along with your
typical health and magic meters
you have brave points or bp and rather
than a standard defend command you can
choose to default which both defends and
banks bp for later use
you can spend up to four actions using
the brave command but if you don't have
enough bp banked you go into debt and
skip future turns undefended this has
always been key to bravely default's
battle system and it remains essentially
untouched here the approach is a little
less novel the third time around but it
still creates a unique wrinkle of
strategic rpg battle planning do you go
into debt to unleash a flurry of attacks
or do some emergency healing do you bank
first and take damage the first few
turns bravely veterans will fall right
back into the habit but nothing about it
feels too complex that it should give
newcomers trouble and newcomers will be
able to jump in here because like final
fantasy bravely default 2's story is
disconnected from any continuity
finally an opponent who might
actually be worthy of my time
[Music]
but you cannot stop the inevitable
to stop you will be enough welp
bravely default has also been known for
its job system another throwback to
games like final fantasy v
as you level up your heroes in different
jobs they'll gain access to new active
and passive abilities and when you
switch to a new job you can set a
subclass to retain some of your
previously learned skills
at their best bravely games recall
classics like final fantasy tactics by
allowing you to experiment and combine
job abilities in ways that feel
almost like cheating and the best way
you could combine a job that attracts
enemy aggression with a passive ability
that boosts your power level every time
you sustain an attack
or pair are regenerating mana points
pool ability with a spellcaster who
specializes in high cost damage dealing
exploring and finding these combinations
feels like solving a puzzle and becoming
a tactical mastermind
here i go
[Music]
maybe sorry
deep guys true to its roots bravely
default is a grind heavy series
both leveling up and mastering the wide
variety of jobs available takes hours of
battling low level enemies in dungeons
but both bravely default and bravely
second greased these squeaky wheels with
some welcome features you could toggle
the encounter rate to occur more
frequently in the overworld set your
characters to auto battle and adjust the
combat speed to fast forward through
encounters
bravely default jettison some of these
options and suffers for it enemy
encounters are no longer random you see
enemies roaming around the overworld and
you run into them to initiate
so your time in the world is spent
hunting down visible creatures you can
no longer set the characters to auto
battle either instead you need to
manually prompt your characters or hit
the repeat last action function
because of this leveling your party
feels like old school grinding again
both commanding your near full attention
and significantly slowing the process of
hunting enemies the experience and job
progression milestones are set
roughly as high as they were in the
previous two games but with the
shortcuts removed regularly leveling
your characters for the next tough boss
becomes a chore
battles can still be sped up but the
default speed setting is so languid it's
hard to imagine ever playing in anything
but two times or three times speed
being able to turn up the speed mid
battle certainly helps mitigate the
level grinding by making individual
battles snappier but the lack of
automation is still a drag
the bravely games had created a
beautiful blend of systems with auto
battles and counter rate sliders and
battle speed sliders
those systems worked in concert with
each other to trim the extraneous work
of classic rpgs while keeping the
substance
still having the option to increase the
battle speed is better than nothing but
it also makes the absence of the other
quality of life improvements that much
more pronounced
[Music]
our quest must go on
[Music]
this is interesting all of this is
delivered with a presentation that's
better looking than ever before
and still endearingly simplistic despite
its look though bravely default explores
some heavy themes
one chapter centers around the death of
a child and how the grief and guilt has
impacted her parents and family friends
another has themes of religious
persecution echoing the salem witch
trials with its chief inquisitor
convinced he's obeying divine influence
instead of his own prejudices these
stories are delivered like vignettes as
individual chapters will shift the focus
to an entirely new cast of characters in
locale
these story beats exist within a
minimalist framework and that disarming
contrast made their tonal impact hit
harder than if they'd been delivered in
a game that was more overtly grisly or
philosophical
given that sophisticated approach to
individual story moments though it's
disappointing that the overarching plot
is so threadbare
the vast majority of the story involves
an evil empire waging war on surrounding
kingdoms in pursuit of power
and four chosen heroes of light are
looking to defend the world from
encroaching darkness
lord commander good to see you back what
have you to report
lonsdale king vernon of alceonia has
formally rejected our offer of an
alliance
how shall we respond
for now we do not
very well we march soon make sure your
troops are ready
the characters are likable particularly
the scholar elvis who sports a thick
rogue and addresses the rest of the cast
like an elder statesman but they're
mostly not much more than archetypes
of course there's a little more to it
but the story doesn't come off as
self-aware or winking about its own
stock standard presentation it's almost
entirely straight faced which is hard to
sustain for a 50-hour adventure
i say almost because the bravely serious
has a habit of taking wild swings with
huge metatextual twists
bravely default 2 is no exception and
after the credits roll it becomes clear
there's more to uncover
i've only started to scratch the surface
of this post-game content but what i've
seen looks audacious
one scene even reminded me of the left
field twist from bravely second though i
have yet to see how bravely default 2
pays off this narrative development
based on the several hours of post-game
content i've seen
however saving the twist and more game
content for as long as bravely default 2
does proves to be another stumbling
block
the enjoyment of a bravely game comes
from tinkering with the job mechanics
and finding game breaking combinations
of abilities
the jobs available throughout the vast
majority of bravely default 2 are fairly
typical even pictomancer one of the more
creative editions
is still essentially a standard buff and
debuff support job
as such there's not much playfulness in
cooking up an overpowered job
combination throughout the main story
and the sluggish pace of leveling up
means it's hard to get a wide array of
abilities that could combo well anyway
this may change in the post game but
finishing a grind heavy 50 hour rpg
before reaching that point is a heavy
lift
without a doubt the lady where the light
led
are those voices but
whose
i'm left with mixed feelings about
bravely default 2. there's a lot to like
and a core that's still fun and engaging
but the removal of some key quality of
life features gives this experience a
lot more friction than the prior games
i've loved the bravely default series
for letting me feel like i'm 15 again
with all the time in the world to grind
out a full set of level 99 characters
while still respecting my time by
recognizing that i don't
actually want to do that bravely default
2 asked me to put in the tedious work
and lost some of the series identity in
the process
[Music]
i'm going all in
[Music]
[Music]